cigarette smoking is one of the most
important global health products the
World Health Organization estimates that
tobacco kills about six million people
each year cigarette smoking has a causal
effect on many cancers heart disease
stroke crisper Tauri diseases you name
it but everybody knows this right and
yet for decades cigarette ad showed half
healthy men smoking but reality is
something hard to argue against at least
for marburo men died of smoking related
diseases and some well-known Hollywood
actors also advertised sirits one died
of cancer the other of dementia which
begs a question
thus smoking has a causal effect on the
risk of dementia there are biological
reasons why smoking may increase the
risk of at least some forms of dementia
however we will never have a randomized
trial of cigarette smoke fortunately
such an ethical trial is not allowed
that means that we'll have to rely on
observational data only in fact several
observational prospective studies of
smoking and dementia have been conducted
since the 1990s however the findings of
this observational studies vary
dramatically some studies found a higher
risk of dementia in smokers and
non-smokers other studies found the
opposite can we interpret any of these
associations as The effect of a smoking
on dementia and if so what's the answer
does smoking cause or prevent dementia
and most importantly why do results
differ across studies one possibility is
and control compounding in some of the
studies for example by alcohol people
who we can cigarette smokers also tend
to drink more alcohol if alcohol
increases the risk of dementia then we
would expect to find an association
between smoking and dementia even if
smoking had no effect on dementia but it
looks like many observational studies of
smoking and the main seein did adjust
for the most important confounders
then why did the smokers have a higher
risk of the maintained some studies and
a lower risk of the main change other
studies
let me give you a hint perhaps it has to
do with the selection of individuals in
each of these studies we will return to
this problem at the end of this lesson
and by then you will be able to explain
what's going on here